in five four three two one
hello and welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast boom og cast
today with me and Joe Jitsu Kalwa
talking about some [ __ ] how's
everybody's week how's everybody been
how'd I do my two pepo you guys shot the
pilot to danger boy yeah man 5 days
non-stop 5:00 a.m. to 6 p.m. you guys is
this a film or is this a episodic so
this is a series you got five dollars
coming out of you like just flying out
of your body like it's [ __ ] spit I
can't help it yeah it's um we're just
it's kind of a pilot okay you know um
what we plan to do is shout out to my
buddy Kelly she sold a few projects to
Netflix mhm and she's gonna kind of shop
it around and we're gonna see what
happens our first goal is to get it
someone funded funded they like like a
big like Netflix or whoever to buy it
yeah and then produced though the the
rest of the episodes yeah that's that
strategy number one you know strategy
number two is we just finish it on our
own and then yeah we just hit the market
with it what type of a series is it like
it's short like well it's it's like a 22
minute it's not like long-form TV okay
so it's like reno911.com at so it's like
it's like a mockumentary kind of thing
oh yeah it's a mock you may or yeah so
the concept is so we follow the least
dangerous gang of the San Gabriel Valley
okay the world's least dangerous game so
imagine like you know the guys that we
grew up with like in the 90s and in the
early 2000s that are like hella thug
right yeah so it's like we know these
guys but then imagine if they never let
go of that thug life man actually know a
couple people like that and in um you
know because that was their like they
were that was their heyday you know yeah
and and so uh but they're like halfway
thugs yeah so they're imagine like
living today and trying to navigate with
that mentality
yeah you know what the funny thing is
like I think I even now I know a couple
people like that who can't who just live
in that weird time capsule oh yeah they
don't they still well I have one friend
who is cuz he went to the military when
he was 18
also he just kind of time to stop and
then he left at a military and he came
back and in exactly so whatever he was
left with at that time his clothing the
way that he speaks his his mannerisms
what he got to do is everything is
everything is exactly the same since we
were 18 years old so fun funny enough
mariel got to meet this guy
when he came and visited from sacramento
because he I guess he got stationed back
in California and so he was like yo like
imma be in LA let's kick it and then I
had to give her heads up I was like hey
when you meet this guy just don't judge
me based on what he does but these these
are the type of people I used to hang
out with you know so like the first
thing he does when he comes up and we're
in Cape Town by the way and you know
back in the day you like using the
n-word was cool yeah but he lives in a
time capsule yeah so he comes up he goes
what's up man I'm like oh Dawg like
let's just huh
wow it's just I mean like he didn't come
with like I guess like him and a couple
other friends and they're black so it's
just like but even then the times are
different yeah I know what he's just
screaming and at the top of his [ __ ] and
I'm like yellow dog like we don't we
don't use that word anymore like that
especially on in public yeah
and so for him he just never really
changed to the wow he drinks how he
talks the way he dresses
yeah well dressed like he just got out
of prison like stalking my like the bag
you like South Pole jeans invitation
like this yeah but it's weird though
like when uh there's definitely a few
people who just kind of live in their
past and they don't they don't move on
yeah it's very true yeah and it's this
story's literally about that you know
like kind of guys that like they just
want to be hard it's like really what is
it to be a man in 2019 like this whole
idea of a masculinity it's so it's weird
now you know like yeah I almost feel
like there is no manuscript er it's not
as easy as it used to be mmm like before
it's like oh if you're a badass or if
you're like some hero or you're like
some like tough guy like oh you're manly
you know yeah and but now it's different
there's so many different ways to
press being a man is [ __ ] so yeah I
think when I was younger too there's a
lot of things that I wish I would have
done earlier but I didn't because [ __ ]
yeah you're like oh I'm afraid
everyone's gonna call me gay yeah so I
didn't join choir for the longest time
because which is so [ __ ] dumb because
that's what gets the ladies bra exactly
so like I didn't join quiet I wanted to
join theater in high school but no I
don't want to be put as like a theater
geek or maybe even get bullied there's
just like these weird things that I
thought where I look back now if I if I
was a stronger individual I would have
just done what I wanted and like because
I did that during my senior year of high
school and it was the best year that I
had because I was like [ __ ] it I'm not
gonna be here anyway to join choir did
whatever I wanted and get picked on I
mean I never really got picked on in
high school do they talk [ __ ] to you for
sure anyway I think ruff the good thing
the good thing is like around that time
I used to jump around different groups
yeah so there was a certain group that
you know was very supportive of it yeah
they just you know oh you could sing you
can do all this other stuff you could
play music and it was great and those
were the friends that I still have today
but you know some of the other homies
thought it was pretty [ __ ] gay yeah I
think would always crack jokes and made
me feel weird about it and [ __ ] yeah but
you know when I was 18 I was like you
know what I'm gonna leave to I'm going
to I'm going to college yeah I'm gonna
see these [ __ ] anyway so I'll just
bounce and move on so I just did
whatever I wanted I was really happy I
was too lazy man I saw I saw a school
play and I was like that's tight and I
wanted to join TV I want to join all
those things and then the only thing I
did join was the mechanic we had a we
had an auto shop at our school oh we had
that too in our high school yeah so like
it but it was like uh what was it like
seventh period or whatever like after
school is that sixth period yeah you
know how it's like yeah yeah you get
that extra one
I took it then I was so damn tired I
would just sleep in class all day
haven't learned [ __ ] about cars but um
yeah people they would tell me like all
you just got to sign up to this and then
you could go in and and you could be a
part of theater group or like you could
be part of the golf club or whatever you
know my RI and I never got around to
doing it so I think my laziness [ __ ]
me up yeah and I also wanted to join
home act and I never did home eck oh
that seems fun cuz everyone was like
baking [ __ ] yeah yeah
but then you know people buy have some
female [ __ ] or you know so it's a good
way to meet girls man I'm saying I
didn't really think about this oh you
know but that that that little sense of
masculinity has changed so much now
because now there's like phrases like
what toxic masculinity yeah it's just
like thrown around a lot now cuz I don't
even know if you people can say openly
like a man up I think people get mad at
that [ __ ] really if you say like you'll
man the [ __ ] up though was this supposed
to me what do you mean man up I still
say I don't care if people I'm like man
quit being a [ __ ] like cuz guys and
girls can't both be [ __ ] yeah you
know to me doesn't mean like you're a
girl or anything like that yeah it's
like a coward is what it is yeah it just
sounds better it does it who says who
calls anyone coward that's like a 1940's
diss you got that coward your scallywag
yeah like who says coward like I rather
say [ __ ] it just feels better dude yeah
and then yeah I don't know man when I
found out recently too [ __ ] speaking
of high school so if anybody has done
like kendama before you know I remember
kendama
yeah and you know how it evolved and got
really crazy yeah people started doing
all these crazy tricks with it well this
is guy in my high school that was in my
class named Dave Matteo Dave Matteo was
like a pioneer for the [ __ ] he can
started incorporating dance moves and
also the [ __ ] uh-huh he was like one of
the top kendama people in the world I
found out yesterday that he actually
killed himself he committed suicide
no [ __ ] way [ __ ] crazy man and the
crazy thing is and I think I think the
saddest part about it is that you know
there's not many people in Sacramento
that gets known for doing some kind of
crazy art yeah you know and he was one
of the few that that did I mean it was
kendama and you know it's very niche or
niche but it he was at the top of
whatever you know he whatever he was
doing I think when people see that they
go oh whoa he like he's so dope why
would he [ __ ] kills I think he had a
wife and a kid too
which is it Sam this is recently this
was like a couple days ago oh my friend
my other friend killed himself over the
weekend too oh really yeah damn do this
so [ __ ] crazy yeah he hung himself
yeah he did the og way dude no one no
one really I mean he still lived at home
with his sister and his parents and he's
my age he's in his 30s oh [ __ ] he's
[ __ ] young dude yeah and um I mean at
was posting about it and it's closer to
him than I was yeah
and they were
I think they went to like junior high or
whatever but he was letting me know
first thing in the morning - and we were
cool I I just I mean but I wasn't that
close the way he was you know like the
you know they had this whole big group
of friends they're like 40 deep they've
been friends things like yeah it's
almost like their whole class we're
friends from like junior high to high
school and college and and I remember
when we went to Vegas man these guys I
felt like they were a party bus by
themselves yeah they just roll deep and
and yeah and in this party group you
know they're there they're always
awesome the and this guy was like you
know he will always play poker together
hang out really cool guy mm-hmm and then
you know I would never expect him to do
something like this so it's just it's
just kind of shocking that people you
never know what's going on in their
minds and then this kind of stuff
happens yeah cuz he was all because Dave
specifically I mean dave was a crazy
[ __ ] man like I remember Dave
Mateo he used to like in class this
[ __ ] would just start doing back
flips Wow he was hyper athletic right it
was just a very athletic ly talented
dude he could dance the [ __ ]
could play the guitar like none other
and he picked it up super late in high
school even later than I did and he was
way better than me
tennis he was really great at tennis he
could dance he was he was a part of a
the Sacramento Bee boy group called
underground flow and actually two of
their friends from high school they
actually uh there the they danced and
kynges oh wow so Michael and Steven
there's a lot of dancers from Sacramento
haha but do dance was huge in Sacramento
man like d-trix is out there if I feel
tired from the Jabbawockeez yeah yeah
Victor Kim germ beats and John Street
from the stereotypes well they're not
dancers or you know producers our boy
Vince
oh yeah you could I mean like dance it's
a dance and art is pretty big in
Sacramento so when I hear it whenever I
hear somebody who from my hometown that
has done something with animated into
career it's very nice to hear especially
because a majority of people in
Sacramento they're actually state
workers like oh yeah cuz it's the state
capitol so I mean everyone's politics or
farms right
I think it's like 70% or it was like a
ridiculous number war for the [ __ ]
state so remember when we went into that
huge recession and [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] ton of
state workers got let off got uh got
fired Oh what I thought the government
will be like the last place that runs
out of money oh because like California
was bankrupt yeah so the state was
bankrupt or something and a whole bunch
of state workers lost their jobs and
there was like these ten nations that
were being put up in Sacramento just
politicians and [ __ ] homeless politician
but just like state workers - so whether
you're working for like the water
department yeah actually or whatever
there was just a lot of employees that
lost their jobs and so when I hear and
because that's what a majority people do
not to knock on them but just you know
just to see somebody go outside of that
yes pretty cool and then Dave - Dave was
just like that's too super like Rasta
dude uh-huh just about love and peace
and they he was a vegan - he had a wife
and kid and you would have thought that
he had he was the kendama guy he's at
the kendama guy damn yeah and anybody
who does kendama if I say Dave Matteo
they know who the [ __ ] that it was a
pretty big deal yeah he's a pretty big
deal in the kendama world which I didn't
really know about cuz I don't I don't
really look into kendama like that is he
white now he's Filipino oh I was just
thinking back because I I remember
seeing some [ __ ] recently about the
number-one like unnatural way of dying
for white males right now is suicide oh
really and an addiction to painkillers
damn like so those are the two things
that like middle-aged white males that
are I guess it's just an epidemic man
okay you know I was thinking about this
the other day too especially because of
you know this recent talk about suicide
um I wonder what it is that causes
people to really get into that because
I've never had those thoughts so I know
and I had a podcast recently with cat
from cats with sweets and bakery where
she was talking Oh was she here yeah she
was here I interviewed her because of
some of the stuff that she went through
which would be on the podcast but her
like I don't know what gets somebody to
that point and I'm starting to think
like have people just throughout history
committed suicide a lot and it just
wasn't recorded or people didn't openly
talk about it or
that's been happening more recently yeah
that's interesting because I know in
Japanese culture suicide wasn't I mean
it's bad but it's not the way it is in
America yeah I think with the
judeo-christian values suicide is almost
like murder yeah because it's it's
illegal it's sin right so if you if you
if you kill yourself you're basically
committing murder yeah um but it's not
the same in Japanese culture no so it
was actually an honourable way to go if
you made a mistake and it's like well
how sorry are you
and it's like I'm really sorry this is
how sorry I am
I'm sorry Olympics yeah it's it's like
oh yeah sorry
dude people like let's say like if you
if you had a son your general right and
your son's a captain or whatever and
then he went out and he lost a battle he
would literally just [ __ ] do seppuku
he would kill his he would he would go
on the whole army [ __ ] say my bad dad
and then he would [ __ ] spill his guts
literally that's [ __ ] crazy
yeah so there's a lot of incidences like
that and nowadays that's why it's like
the seppuku culture right where it's
like you hear these stories and right
now Japan and Korea is I think competing
versus like on who's got the highest
suicide rate yeah but that's why it's so
common in Japan where it's like oh [ __ ]
I [ __ ] up this test oh well let's hit
that reset button you know and then
they'll hit that reset button and they
believe in reincarnation so they'll just
come back anyway so but it's not
honorable you know like the now like if
you if you commit suicide or whatever
like the whole family will be upset and
sad and all that but they also expect
they also is like it's more like hey I'm
a burden I'm sorry for causing so much
[ __ ] like let me do my restart button
yeah so in that sense I think it might
be a cultural way but I don't think it's
a naturally human thing to do it yeah
what was your buddy just seemingly okay
on the outside like everything seemed
pretty I haven't seen him in ages I mean
recently I seen him like at a wedding
just once in passing because uh somebody
one of our buddies got married sighs I
mean I said
to everybody mm-hmm but I didn't have
enough time to really like be there and
talk to him mm-hmm
again I wasn't that close so it's always
been this like let's kick it let's party
relationship yeah
and I do know some people I guess like
now in retrospect like aunt and and some
people were telling me that what ended
up happening was he was very depressed
and then when they would hang out and
drink together like he would get kind of
a bit aggressive or uncontrollable with
his with his alcohol yeah and it wasn't
always like that he used to be a happy
drunk and I guess people stopped
inviting him because he couldn't control
his liquor
I was gonna look crazy with it and then
he started thinking that people were
talking [ __ ] about him and it's like
no-one's talking [ __ ] about you bro they
just don't like the way that you can't
handle your liquor and you get
aggressive yeah so they are in that
sense talking [ __ ] but like no one's
literally saying like you're a [ __ ]
loser or anything like that yeah but I
think he's projecting his own
insecurities you know and and so I guess
he stopped going out he stopped going to
events he stopped hanging out with that
group he's just stayed home all day and
so people started visiting him and then
and then they're making sure he's all
right and they're like oh why don't you
come to this baby shower why don't you
come to this or whatever and I guess
this is my take on everything we are
getting older were and we're out of age
now where it's like hey we're starting
to get into our careers we're starting
to make more money you start to see the
fruits of our Labor's from our 20s right
so you start seeing all the guys in
their 30s with homes and maybe a
marriage with a kid or you start to see
all these things so I think for him he
hasn't really checked off those bucket
list things so seeing all your friends
do all this stuff maybe make some made
him feel low in life that [ __ ] really
[ __ ] people up though that that age and
that timeline thing oh well a hundred
percent is I got asked recently that is
funny that you mentioned that I got
asked recently from this buddy of mine
he was an actor in guk
and he went on when I went to go when I
was in New York for Sanford's I got I
grab the drink with them and he asked me
just throughout within the conversation
he asked me what what did turning thirty
field like right he has he's he's a
couple years younger than me he goes oh
yeah so you know just give me a heads up
about what it feels like to be thirty
because I'm not to hit that mark like
it's a big pivotal moment yeah and so
for me I couldn't really grasp what that
meant you know and I I guess for most
people it's kind of like how people
celebrate holidays when they work a
nine-to-five oh yeah for us it's just
whatever right cuz we're just working
whether it's a holiday or not it doesn't
really make a damn difference yeah and I
think when people look at certain age
marks they they feel like they have to
hit certain milestones and for me I've
never really felt that and that's a lie
I did when I was younger and then when I
started you know just basing my goals on
when I wanted to finish things
I just felt a lot of pressure was
relieved yeah because it just it's kind
of it's kind of dumb where they say oh
you have to have why don't you have a
house my house right now when you're at
this age why aren't you married at this
age and how you have to live by those
timelines like I understand it's it's a
societal like unspoken rule kind of you
know like I also think that people
always are comparing themselves to
others to know where they're at at life
and I'm like you to like I I'm not I
don't give a [ __ ] about what other
people are doing but I realized that
it's very important to a lot of people
because that's how they check if they're
[ __ ] up or not you know like if they
go oh [ __ ] you know what like all my
friends are getting married it's like Oh
am i [ __ ] around too much maybe I
should settle down and or like you know
they'll everyone's buying houses um [ __ ]
is that the responsible thing to do
maybe I should get one too and if they
don't get one maybe they feel
irresponsible so that's what I realized
about that kind of mentality it's like
people are always trying to gauge their
worth their value their where they're at
in this world are they a loser are they
a winner like there's a lot of that
going on yeah I think the better thing
for people to do is not to really do
that but just to always check on how
happy you are right yeah because
I think there's a lot of people who have
done that where they felt like they
should be at a certain point in their
life for example have a house have a
wife have a kids but they jumped into it
way early yeah they're in this place
that they don't want to be they didn't
want kids they didn't want to settle
down early and then they start to feel
regret yeah because they were forced
into this this description of what they
should be at a certain age and they
didn't get to live life the way that
they wanted yeah because prior to me
really figuring out who I am and
figuring out what what what made me
happy all I could think about was
getting married having kids and having
that white picket fence at a house now
you thought that was happiness I really
I really truly did and I think that's
where everyone's at is like they think
oh if I got those things I'd be happy
yeah and not to say there aren't people
out there who got who who will get that
and be happy like um one of my friends
hurt her husband now yeah his definition
of happiness is to have a bunch of kids
settle down play with these kids and
live in a house with his wife for the
rest of his life right and that's his
definition but that's just his
definition yeah so you're yours all
about you're basically saying just align
yourself with who you are and live that
life you don't let other people tell you
like what it should be even with having
kids yeah if you don't want to have a
kid don't [ __ ] have a kid yeah you
have a [ __ ] kid Billy well I want my
legacy on my seat to live on [ __ ] are
you ready for the what's coming exactly
like this is true it's it's just a weird
constant for me yeah cuz you know how
I'm recently single right and I'm 35 and
then like I I do read [ __ ] like from
people that are like oh man it must be
so it must be so sad to be like that age
and then like you're alone and I'm like
what are you talking about it's one of
the best feelings in the world yeah I
mean you were tied down in a
relationship for [ __ ] five years yeah
and you know it the the the latter half
of it was you trying to figure out if
this is gonna work for you or not and
now you finally have that time of space
to go back and work on yourself exactly
[ __ ] blessing and a lot of people
don't see it like their own yeah but I -
well it's because they you know people
think that being alone is loneliness
yeah and it's not there's a difference
between being single and alone and being
a lonely
person I could be in a relationship and
still feel lonely which I did for the
last year but you can still feel like
you could be alone and you can still be
full of love and like warmth with with
people and family and all that stuff
yeah and and I was like oh is that
because people are so dependent on the
need for someone to love them that
that's why they they look at my
situation and go oh that's sad
yeah and I'm like oh I mean it just goes
back to like you know you got to find
what makes you happy right and then for
me I kind of like go wherever the wind
blows so I don't really have a set thing
like oh like I always talked about how
like oh if I have a farm and all this
stuff it's become is it's it's it's
awesome but it's a goal and I goals
never make me happy like what makes me
happy as my state of mind wherever I'm
at hmm so wherever we go if the thing
that I expected didn't happen it's like
oh well yeah I don't care like I'm still
[ __ ] chilling yeah a huge part of
what I enjoy about life is the journey
and the process yeah you know and like
I'm you know Mariel makes me happy you
know but I'm not gonna lie there are
times when I'm just like I just want to
cut this [ __ ] line and be free and
I'll be real to you even Mariel feels
like that sometimes yeah cuz Mariel was
a very independent girl yeah and you're
both very independent and so this stage
of us being with each other all the time
is is new for both of us
yeah and you're working it out yeah and
it's normal to have friction a [ __ ]
causes us to clash all the time and we
have to figure this out because I mean
just as an example because we want to
move out of our current place yeah right
and then there was a an argument that we
had that kind of broke you out because I
think it just starts to we just start to
think about all the negative things that
could happen when we move in together
into another place it's like oh how are
we gonna decorate this place she wants
it a certain way I wanted a certain yeah
and no matter what if it goes this way
or that way one of us one of us is gonna
be unhappy simply because we're so hyper
independent and we want things our own
way
it just we tend to clash a lot yeah and
it's because she's always done things
how she wanted and because she lived by
herself and sleeping for me even when I
had the when I lived with roommates
I still got my way and the reason why is
because I paid the most friend uh I pay
the rent I pay the utilities I paid
everything and I bought the furniture so
it was gonna be my way I just paid more
money for it yeah in this case it
doesn't work whether I pay for it or not
she's still gonna have a [ __ ] say
yeah that's what I found out the woman's
gonna win no matter what dude I'm
[ __ ] you know how they win they just
complain to the point where you can't
take it anymore and you just don't care
anymore
yeah there's art man I do when I see
when I sometimes I see you man I might
look at this [ __ ] free ass here's
like a bundle of feathers in the wind
you just tossed that [ __ ] somewhere and
just [ __ ] floats and scatters where
it goes and I'm like that used to be me
I used to just do whatever the [ __ ] I
wanted and I said they should have run
Mariel as well you could you could
always leave me if you want but there's
gonna be a shift like what if you when
you guys do figure this out and then you
know you can coexist
there's gonna be a shift where like if I
am single in the next 20 years right
like you're good you guys are gonna
obviously have kids you guys are gonna
have like more to look forward to and
when all those things are kind of like
said and done then I'm gonna be the
lonely bastard that's like have anything
to do or people to be with on
Thanksgiving or whatever right yeah so
yeah I think it's just a balance there's
got to be that that in between or if I'm
happy with being alone like my brother
he knows exactly what he wants he's like
I don't [ __ ] like people I already
have enough friends I'm cool and I'm
done
well there are a lot of people like that
but I think what when people do get
unhappy is when you're trying to meet an
expectation that doesn't really exist
make other people happy you're afraid of
other people talking [ __ ] or whatever I
think that's what drives people into
this like crazy you know place in their
head yeah that's true though when that
[ __ ] happens you know it's my mom kind
of put it like this cuz you know I kind
of just you know I talked to her a lot
yeah and I I asked her how would you
feel if I said that I did
want any kids at all yeah you know I
just don't want kids and you know of
course she was kind she kind of felt a
little weird about it but I was testing
me - yeah you late son of a [ __ ] II I
want to grandchildren you kiss okay but
she what she said is that she goes you
know the reason why I think people want
to have kids or why you should have kids
is because you're thinking about
yourself right now and how happy you are
without the stress of having children is
because right now you can find purpose
in everything that you do right so
whether you're doing a new business
venture you're working on new projects
that's where your purpose lies she goes
you'll be surprised
and towards the end of your life when
you have said and done majority of
things that you want you you're gonna
wonder where should you place your
attention like where does your hopes and
dreams go to and if you don't have kids
a lot of people feel like your hopes and
dreams dies with everything that you've
done but that's what your kids have and
so you as an old person she goes for me
I I don't live for myself in your honor
she goes I'm healthy and I'm happy now
because I've seen what I've done with
you and I'm living out the rest of my
days to see what happens with you and
that's what makes me excited she goes
there's a point to where you feel lonely
she goes what if what if you you go up
and then your dad dies I still have you
yeah still have your brother yeah you
know there's always a community to come
and help you out and that's why I think
it's important to have kids it also
helps you grow and learn new things and
it's just it's another chapter in your
life like don't don't picture it as your
life ending but it's a new chapter
opening yeah you know it's just a new
story that begins yeah I've heard that
from a lot of people where it's like one
of the best joys of life is just kids
mmm and I'm like that's [ __ ] awesome
thing god I'm a man dude could be fifty
years old and I could be bucking that
yes I can have a kid yeah I mean I won't
be able to see them grow as old as maybe
if I started now yeah but yeah I think
um I don't know I mean I think right now
it's not it's just not even a goal of
mine to have a kid yeah I'm having a kid
I'm not gonna lie like I I do want a kid
but having a kid scares me man it scares
the living [ __ ] [ __ ] out we were in
Hawaii we saw all of our friends with
kids and it was like holy mother crap
dog like just watching Bart geo and and
Christina and how beat up they [ __ ]
look just trying to take I mean they
were having fun too but just to have a
kid wash him off every time he's at the
beach make sure that he's not running
around touching [ __ ] and you just see
how exhausted and tired that they are
that's not me if I go on vacation [ __ ]
those kids they're staying back at home
with my grandpa
you're not coming it's a vacation I'm
coming back looking like I slept yeah
cuz even for us to like it was a short
trip and I you know I love having Bart
you and all them around but it
definitely wasn't the vacation it was
supposed to be because there were kids
there yeah so we have to make
adjustments for that as well and we
don't have kids so I can only imagine
what it's like for them 24/7 they can't
leave it yeah it's not like a dog yeah a
dog could [ __ ] take care of himself
you just put some food and they're good
to go and I'm like alright I'll let you
go pee yeah like I think until like the
kids maybe like eight or nine years old
yeah then I might take them traveling
cuz before then I'm trying to deal with
that [ __ ] it's pretty rough yeah man
like just unless that's all you're doing
I think it's because of our lifestyle
like we you know work is all around us
24/7 mmm-hmm you know we don't separate
all this stuff it's all kind of gray
area I don't know if I could give up my
lifestyle right now yeah even though
it's stressful and it's a lot of work
and you travel a lot too oh yeah gives
you that out of your system the moment I
have a kid this travel is cutting out
yeah I can't leave Merrill with the kid
alone she'll [ __ ] die yeah you know
she'll suffer from this [ __ ] so you got
to get it out of your system before you
do it I got two years man where I just
got to go to Thailand and get my dick
sucked or something yeah I mean that's
what I'm gonna be doing now is just
traveling Joe I always hear the best
things about well I don't know how
people feel about this but prostitution
is pretty high in a lot of these other
countries and everybody tells me really
you know that scene in rush hour I heard
that's just like for real like when the
girls come out and then you take them
and you pick them out I heard that
shit's legit legit I've done that here
in America each ina dug it do it that is
yeah
the irony oh it's a bug [ __ ] what I saw
this podcast is brought to you by purple
baby if you haven't heard of purple then
I feel bad for you son because you got
99 back problems and yes a bat problem
is one so I've been using a purple Mets
for quite a while now and I got to tell
you before this purple mattress my
friends I was dealing with a lot of back
pain I'm on top of back pain I was
dealing was sleeping super hot the
material that a purple mattress is made
out of is developed by rocket scientists
that's how future it is Sun probably the
best sleeps I've ever had in my life
because of this purple mattress because
it's firm and soft at the same time and
I don't know if you guys realize this
but how you sleep and the comfort in
your sleep matters a lot because you
actually spend a good chunk of your life
sleeping if you don't realize that for
some people as an average of five to six
in some people that's like seven and
nine that's a fat chunk out of your
24-hour day so if you are gonna spend
that time sleeping make sure that you do
it right because a good night's sleep is
super important and purple literally and
figuratively easily has your back so
you're going to love purple and right
now my listeners will get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to the great free
gifts they're offering site-wide just
text brain to eight four - eight eight
eight the only way to get this repel o
is the text brain two eight four eight
eight eight that's B are a I n two eight
four eight eight eight and I mean I've
I've done it with the ladies of the
night but then it's not the same well
okay so maybe what gets me off is
different from other other people I like
it when there's a there's a game to it I
like to win and I like it when the girl
likes me so then I realized that I will
I like sometimes I'll have better sex
with a less attractive girl that likes
you more yes then a girl that's just
like [ __ ] it let's just one night stand
but she's not like she's super hot but
maybe like she's not that into me then
that energy
isn't there so when I was younger I just
[ __ ] everything in anything and then I
started to realize like there was a
difference to it all huh
there's like different levels and and I
mean that's probably what girls
experience from the beginning that's why
they're like they want an emotional
connection or some [ __ ] you know cuz
it's just it's just a better experience
overall oh yeah for sure I'm sure like I
just just having those situations I
wonder if I was if I still single and I
went to [ __ ] like Singapore Malaysia
I'm like I'm gonna go to one these
brothels I want to know what's up it's
it's pretty crazy though like just just
to have them walk out and you're just
like oh my god like I could choose any
and I don't have to like court them I
don't have to like hope that they like
me and and ask him out on a date like
it's just bam bam and I'm feeling like
wait like can we talk or some [ __ ] like
can we just like get to know each other
just like two minutes like cuz they're
hella quick cuz they're like bam bam bam
I need to get this money you know cuz
it's the the more the quicker you come
and the quicker that they do this [ __ ]
you do another round yeah but it's so
transactional man like I feel um it's
weird it's just it's not yeah and do
they have the equivalent for four women
like guys will jack off a girl I don't
know it doesn't seem like something like
a woman would do yeah I don't think so
and I mean it's better it better be like
top notch or some [ __ ] I mean I read
this a Cosmo article I was reading a
cosmopolitan article I think it was
Cosmo but it was it was a magazine that
was generally geared towards women and I
could it could have been a maxim I don't
[ __ ] know but it was an article about
a girl about a reporter not just a girl
a reporter and she was trying to get a
jackoff massage for her for herself
yeah and social guy so she was writing
about the experience about how difficult
it is to get to find a place that does
jackoff massages for women oh my god so
she was kind of writing down what the
signals are for what you have to look
for at a place you know if that that if
they'll do it or not guys would be like
I don't even know if you wanted this way
and so she she I forgot what it was that
was like one signal where if they come
up and they brush your thigh or your leg
yeah that's a sign that they'll do it
for you oh she's got the night at 3:00
or 4:00
places before she finally found a place
that would do it first she's like at
Massage Envy and [ __ ] and they're like
this is a reputable [ __ ] organization
if I was a guy massage like therapist
I'd be kind of how is this a trap yeah
yeah it's just so weird no women really
ask for that [ __ ] right so I'm like wait
did I don't have to pay you and I could
play with your [ __ ] like well yeah you
got to go to those spots that just his
massage and there's just a neon oh my
god the second D on foot it works like a
foot massage I heard that the tip was if
a place has closed doors yeah that's a
sign that they bet they'll do it really
that's like the first sign that they'll
do it is if you go into like a seedy
looking place and they have closed doors
you can't if there's only curtains then
no wow so that's like one of the signs
that you that you'll get like a jackoff
massage or some [ __ ] like that that's
crazy we know someone who likes to
frequent those very frequently very very
much there's some [ __ ] funny a
stories about those things too and you'd
be surprised how many jackoff places are
in California there's a lot a [ __ ] ton I
just don't know why it's illegal I don't
know either
because it's not penetration or anything
they should legalize it though because
then it'll be cleaner yeah at least that
I think I wouldn't be creeped out if it
was the [ __ ] part not for me per se
but if there was an establishment that
said foot neck back dick I don't think
that's any different like in Japan it's
all legal
except penetration that's why they have
the the soap lands that were the girl
just [ __ ] covers herself in soap and
then she slides up and down along with
her yeah I supposed to be feel good I
guess it's it's pretty slippery
I never been yeah but then yeah I mean
like we were out there and then they
would have like a bar and the bar would
say [ __ ] and we're like what and I
looked it up and it's like you could
literally drink beer while you get your
dick sucked or like there's all these
other things and I'm like this is crazy
I forgot you know cuz we go through that
little rabbit hole and [ __ ] yeah it was
the same time that I was reading that
that cost Cosmo article but I was
reading something about those [ __ ]
bars I heard
foreigners aren't allowed in there Oh
like foreigners majority of those
[ __ ] bars like foreigners they'll
deny a lot of foreigners yeah but if you
are like a Japanese person or Japanese
citizen as Han but they're just sitting
at the bar stool and there's like this
curtain over and you sit down and you're
talking with your friends you drink a
beer and then you're getting your dick
sucked as you're drinking a [ __ ] Wow
which I would think is weird cuz you
would get whiskey dick yeah but yeah I
forgot what I what the [ __ ] I was
reading I don't know how I got to this
thing but there was an interview with
one of those sex workers Wow yeah and
just kind of bosses behind it - but
Japan's [ __ ] insane it is Korea has a
whole row of this area in Korea yeah I
don't know where it's at but it's legal
it's legal prostitution from what I
remember but there's just a lot of these
like love hotels as they call them yeah
and like businessmen just go and go in
there to get their dick sucking [ __ ]
yeah I mean I might try it like if I'm
travelling and if it's there like if
it's legal in that country yeah cuz I
don't wanna the thing I'm scared about
is like yeah it'sit's it's hella sad
like that she could turn sad easily yeah
but then when you see like in Amsterdam
or like when women are more like yeah
[ __ ] yeah confident about it like I
think that's a turn-on to me too like
when you go to the strip club at Vegas
or whatever like they're more like I'm
doing this like this is my [ __ ] that's
very different yeah cuz in Amsterdam
it's it's like taxed and everything yes
it's an actual business yeah and I think
at that point I wouldn't be like I don't
want that thought in the back of my head
lies a slave yeah it's so weird I could
just go suck yeah and then but if I if
it's like nah like this is their
profession
they [ __ ] signed up for it and they're
like owning it and it benefits their
taxes then I feel like cool like they
signed up for this you know it's very
different
oh I know for a fact whenever I go to
Asia and I'm in an area and I see a
bunch of [ __ ] fat white dudes I know
what you're there for you're trying to
get your dick sucked by a little
teenager you little sick [ __ ] yeah and
that's the other thing too
so like I like Asian American girls like
uh I don't really find Asian girls in
Asia that like I try the standard is
different remember that wholesome ulu
article about what they found yeah
they don't find likes EMU attractive but
it will ask an Asian American girl a lot
of girls think he's really hot yeah so
it's a different taste because yeah I
think like the girls out there they look
really cute you know like little
children yeah I feel like they're too
cute to wear it's like a Leicester five
yeah so sex appeal but in the girls here
there's sex appeal they're sexy or lured
not just cute but there's like other
parts of it they look like more like
women to me I think it's also because of
the type of women that we grew up around
they're a lot more curvaceous and yeah
that's that's the women that I think
typically that we find physically really
attractive that's true because there's
and even if there was like hot girls
that are like I guess like ladies of the
night or whatever in Asia I don't think
I'd go for it yeah and there's like a
bunch of Asian like beauty bloggers and
I've had a conversation with a couple of
my girlfriends but they're like oh you
know this asian beauty blogger and and
whatever and they go is she so like hot
like as a girl judging another girl yeah
and I look at them and I'm like that is
not hot I was like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about what do you mean hot and
they're like no she's super pretty I'm
like yeah maybe for like a [ __ ]
twelve-year-old you know because if
their makeup gurus right what they're
based on is like their face is really
pretty yeah but you know and this is not
a knock on them this is just a
preference I mean obviously the guys
fawn over them but for my taste and
preference no yeah it just depends on
the guy a lot of the age I think a lot
of Asian female bloggers for for
depending in comparison to a lot of the
women that I grew up around they're just
a little too thin for what I like you
know physically speaking yeah right so
but I find it I find you know thicker
more curvaceous women more attractive
and then the guys that probably see the
girls that were attracted to would be
like oh they're fat yeah yeah so it's
all prefaced like taste and preference
yeah cuz sometimes like when I like I'm
not you know I'm not gonna name names
but you know there was like one Asian
beauty blogger that everybody loves and
like yo so hot I'm like in what way bro
her eyes and her calves are the same
size but some some people [ __ ] with that
dude yeah Asia yeah they love that
[ __ ] thin thin man yeah I'm like bro
like I need some titties man
I'll be like some you know like speed
bumps that leave it there like that
famine body do they want that rib dude
I'm like bro what the [ __ ] dog I know
exactly what you're talking about what
are you doing yeah innit oh man there's
nothing to grab but like what do you
grab it
yeah and it's sad because III don't know
if the girls are like if they just
naturally don't eat that much out there
or like or they're they're forced to
believe that they gotta stay this way to
be pretty and all that [ __ ] and I'm like
girl you man somebody give you a
dumpling or something goddamn yeah they
just don't look physically capable yeah
right it's that foot binding [ __ ] man
it's the same the same thing for like I
need a girl that could [ __ ] pull a
rickshaw and [ __ ] oh yeah there's got a
boulder out of there oh she got the
[ __ ] long stick with the two [ __ ]
baskets of rice I know give me one of
those peasant girls man [ __ ] no [ __ ]
royalty they're too scared I think the
girls that that I think physically I
find attractive I think a lot of people
find them maybe too fat maybe like yeah
that too fat like like for example
Muriel she used to not like her legs and
her calves why I I think she thought
they were too fat cuz she kind of she
grew a lot of like Korean people but
they're muscular they're nice and toned
she looks athletic exactly I asked what
I like yeah it's so funny that's what I
like even when I was like 270 pounds of
like I like athletic women but she yeah
and when she was younger she didn't like
those things because she wanted the
thigh gap she wanted the thin legs
because the girls are rounder and I
think she grew up in what diamond barge
yeah Hills area or something and I think
a lot of guys found those thick skinny
girls really cute
no wonder girls are so [ __ ] about how
they should look oh yeah yeah they they
don't that looks like it's like they
have their own standard like within
girls you know how like they have a
whole different set of what they think
is beautiful mm-hmm and then you have
guys with so many different preferences
right so they
like they might go like oh I'm crushing
on his guy but then his preference might
be like you know something like long ass
legs yeah you know like he might like
girls that are like way more thicker or
whatever you know what man just [ __ ]
do you that's what I'm saying just do
you you'll find somebody that'll find
like the worst qualities about you
attractive you know and my best example
is this when I take photos of people
it's funny how people are so so
selective about the way that they look
right because I like taking pictures of
people when they're not posing and when
they're not looking
specifically because it just kind of
shows a side to them that other people
can't see the candid ones they're very
candid ions right just kind of them in
their element and a lot of people hate
those photos that I take of then why I
think like the photos you take they want
because they want to pose they want to
pose and they want to show a side that
not I want you to show my double chin
they want people to see a side that they
personally feel is attractive but you
don't know the beauty that somebody else
sees in you right that's true cuz
they're so critical because that's so
critical of ourselves they go because a
lot of the times like I'll post a
picture right and they'll be okay with
anything oh that's that wasn't my
favorite picture oh they wouldn't say
take it down David it shows my [ __ ]
blemishes so but they're okay with it
after they read the comments and they're
like yo this is a beautiful picture but
they just don't see it you know so how
you perceive yourself and how the rest
of the world perceives you might be
different because you're not gonna love
all the qualities that everybody else
loves about you because you just you
just don't you're so critical of
yourself yeah and you're right
especially for a girl there's certain
standards that you have to have because
nobody uh if I use this as an example in
terms of comedy when a guy does like a
really dumb and goofy face I think it's
just it gets more interaction a lot more
likes because of how hilarious it is but
if a girl does it sometimes it won't get
as much interaction as a fine girl with
like look like a fat ass or a finance
body and she's half-naked even though
the comedies the same as the guy the guy
will get more likes and there's more
interaction with it because that's what
they expect out of them because a lot of
the times with girls especially on a
visual platform the only expecting them
to look pretty and not really have a
brain yeah and that's not what they're
really looking for when they follow them
either so I think that's just my example
of how hard it is sometimes to be a girl
because no matter
how not no matter but sometimes when you
want people to recognize you for other
things it just it kind of gets outshined
just by yeah a sickly look I think it
depends on how it starts yeah yeah like
if they started being a bikini model and
all of a sudden they they want to put on
they start talking about all the ticks
and [ __ ] it's like girl I just jack off
to you man yeah you do we got off on the
wrong foot yeah you can't be making me
horny and then make me want to vote
afterwards like it's the other way
around too like I'm not making anybody
horny yeah be the weirdest thing if I
did right yeah it is yeah
so if we started off yeah I think it's
just attractive people in general
because like if guys are out there being
attractive and that's all they did and
all of a sudden they want to do
something else like stand-up comedy yeah
who's gonna get [ __ ] roasted yeah yeah
you're not gonna be accepted with open
arms yeah so it's like man stick to
modeling fo like get the [ __ ] out of
here
yeah it's perception of what you started
with yeah and it's what yeah that's the
hard part because if you if you kind of
put yourself out as something that got
you really popular and then you do that
shift people haven't really subscribed
to them you know it's the same probably
I came here to jack off not to listen to
your thoughts yeah oh [ __ ] well that's
actually [ __ ] yeah I always do this we
had we had a topic at a question to get
into let's do that on the next video
next podcast all right well you guys you
guys can catch us you guys can catch us
on all the audio platforms we're talking
about Spotify and iTunes if you see us
on iTunes make sure you give us that
five star I remember this podcast is a
podcast about anything and everything
and we're just here to be with you on
your everyday commute when you work or
if you just want somebody to talk your
[ __ ] ear off
yeah Joe okay thank you yeah
you guys you want to go and watch out
for [ __ ] danger boys baby danger boys
we're gonna try to do it tor and the
only way you can see it is live
oh [ __ ] that's the only way and then you
got a screen it mm-hmm
oh dude it's gonna be [ __ ] fun man
hell yeah cool alright y'all we'll see
y'all next time thanks peace